I believe that it's important to support
the people who believe the same thing
that you do who on the same mission that
you are on even if they're taking a
slightly different approach to it so I
believe in entrepreneurs right I want to
see you be successful I want to see you
get more to your life I want to see you
turn your idea into reality and start
changing people's lives and I like
supporting people who are on that same
mission and one thing that gets me a
little bit upset as I look at I look at
our media and I look at TV shows that
are out there and there's not a heck of
a lot that supports entrepreneurship
that talks about what it's like to run a
business and gives advice and gives
educational tools to help entrepreneurs
there's sharks tank there's dragons den
here in Canada there's some great shows
about people running their own business
i love i love Pawn Stars a lot of west
coast customs and Count's Kustoms is
some great shows like that but I
recently discovered a show called the
profit and it runs on CNBC and it's it's
with a investor named Marcus lemonis who
goes into companies and gives them his
expertise he invest he gives them his
money and he turns them around and he
helps train the entrepreneur how to be
better he gives him his advice on what
to do to run a better company and he
invests his own dollars into it as well
to make sure that it happens and for the
next week or so he's in there really
helping them out hands on and it's a new
show I think they're just starting their
second season I'm a fan because there
isn't enough quality information out
there especially on TV to help
entrepreneurs you kind of kind of find
it you know I get your searching out
videos like this you're reading certain
blogs or sections of a newspaper but
there's not enough people want to be
entrepreneurs you know everybody has an
idea that they want to turn into the
into reality and and be more and this
has to change and so sharks tank was a
great entry point to that now people are
talking about entrepreneurship the
profit is a great extension of that and
and I believe in what Marcus is doing
and I'm not affiliate with them in any
way I didn't know Marcus before the show
aired I just I'm a fan and I think that
you got to support the things that you
believe in and I think if you guys check
out the show the first couple episodes
are free on YouTube you can watch them
too you're going to learn something
you're going to be entertained you're
going to learn something you can be a
better entrepreneur on your go away
thinking in new ways to make your
business better so check out the profit
on CNBC believe for those are you
watching like the video give it a thumbs
up below subscribe to the channel and
leave a comment below let me know you
have a question for your business I'm a
greedy response thank you so much and
I'll see you soon